let's put chat GPT to the test what is
the equation of the graph y is equal to
the absolute value of x minus 1 plus 7
reflected across the y-axis
I was a bit lazy to work this out myself
so let's see what chat gbt says
to reflect the function y is equal to
the absolute value of x minus 1 plus 7
about the y-axis we replace x with
negative X in the equation of the
function this is because when we reflect
a point or function about the y axis the
x coordinate of each point is negated
while the y coordinate Remains the Same
so we have the function we replace x
with negative X then we simplify to get
that Y is equal to the absolute value of
x plus one plus seven and that gives us
the answer Choice a wow that answer was
too good Math teachers be afraid be very
afraid